hello
my name is michael pewt and today we
will begin our discussion
of classical chinese philosophy one of
the truly great philosophical traditions
in world history
our goal in these sessions will be to
take you through the great philosophers
in the tradition
and particularly to look at how when we
really take these ideas seriously
they will challenge some of our most
fundamental assumptions
and today we begin with the self
what are our assumptions about the self
what would in this case
confucius say about the self and how
would it lead us to fundamentally
rethink our
notions our assumptions and how even
more importantly would it lead us to
live a very very
different life if we are convinced and i
suspect
at least in part we might be convinced
now to begin this discussion
let me start out with some
characteristic assumptions we tend to
make about the self
words phrases thoughts we tend to have
so let me just lay out a few of those so
often times especially when we're
thinking about how to be
a good person how to lead a fulfilled
life we'll use phrases like the
following
well the key is to look within
look within and find oneself so if i'm
speaking of myself i would often say
i just need to look within find myself
find my true self find who i really am
and often we'll think about this in
terms of a life arc so oftentimes we'll
say to children
particularly maybe high school age
moving into college
look within find yourself once you've
found yourself
then learn to love yourself and embrace
yourself for who you are
learn to love your great qualities and
and
love your bad qualities too because
that's just you
and you should love yourself for who you
are and then we will say
now moving into college often once
you've successfully found this true self
that you love and embrace
then you want to start thinking how
rationally to lead your life in ways
that will allow this true self to be
fulfilled
so what career options best fit who i
really
am and we will even start giving
students in fact even beginning in high
school now
personality tests that will help them
find out who they are
what careers will fit who they are what
careers would
not fit who they are and therefore what
careers they should avoid
and then they will hopefully spend their
college years
picking a major that fits who that will
be and
that will propel them into a career that
will best accord
with themselves their true selves
same things with our personal life right
so given who you are
you want to find a partner who matches
who you are
and here too personality tests and now
dating apps will actually help you
match who you are with who you would
best fit with of your type xyz
would you best fit with type ghq
and it will match you up with who is
best for you
and then we like to think as long as i
live my life being true to myself
loving myself rationally deciding
according to what's best for me this
true self
how i fit best in the world we will lead
a
happy and fulfilled life